joining me today is a leader a follower
a reader a writer a speaker a listener a
student a teacher
Jaakko willing welcome to the Rubin
report that was that I took that right
out of the bio that's good right out of
the Twitter bio that's my Twitter bio
yeah yeah I'm a Twitter bot you're a
little bit of everything that actually
is a pretty good explanation of you it
actually it actually is a pretty good
explanation to me
I think I'm cover those multiple
dichotomies fairly well yeah that would
probably explain why you've written
roughly 37 thousand books right how
about how many books have you written I
mean I'd normally only put one book on
the table we slips for he's written so
far written three adult books yeah and
three kids books I've got another kid's
book coming out in the spring and I've
got another adult book coming out going
head-to-head with Jordan Peterson in
January of 20 2000 I probably will be on
tour with him for that book that means
that we're gonna be in competition okay
bring it uh-oh all right we'll see we'll
see
okay so nice to to not actually have to
compete with ya
well do you do you feel like you're in
competition with anyone it's that's an
interesting place to start off well
that's I guess there's a dichotomy there
too because I don't feel like I'm in
competition with anyone and I feel like
I'm in competition that's just sort of
you know in my nature to just compete
but no I mean in this world that I'm in
right now I don't really feel like I'm
competing with anyone I feel like I'm
just kind of doing what I do talking
about what I like to talk about writing
about what I like to write about and
hanging out with cool people most the
time yeah pretty good pretty good
all right well I think 99% of my
audience knows who you are knows a lot
about you but for the people that don't
and by the way I should say me right
before we started I was saying we have
been trying to coordinate this for about
27 years right I mean a long time which
is kind of funny I mean it it really
says it's like well we're two people
that are better busy yeah it was hard to
hard to really make this happen but for
the people that know nothing about you
tell me a little bit about your history
I was born and raised in a small New
England town I was a rebellious kid my
best way to rebel as a kid coming from a
small New England town was to join the
millage
so I joined the military after high
school I spent 20 years in the military
and when I retired from the military I
started taking the things that I had
learned from the military and teaching
them to civilian companies and civilian
leaders and eventually that turned into
a bulk in a podcast and all this other
stuff yeah so tell me a little bit more
about what you were like that made you
want to go into the military what was
that rebellious kid or whatever that
yeah you know I just grew up you know in
a little New England town and there was
a lot of hippies and just kind of kids
like that running around and smoking pot
and whatever and I really wasn't into
that and so you know I got think a lot
of kids when they rebel as kids because
all kids rebelle a lot of kids repelled
by drinking or they do drugs or whatever
they're gonna do and I went the other
direction was like into hardcore music
and eventually said oh yeah I'm just
gonna join the military because that's
what I'm gonna do yeah it's funny when
you talk about it it almost sounds like
you're slightly dismissing it but you
have it you had a pretty good storied
career as a Navy SEAL yeah no I grew up
in the SEAL Teams I went riding the Navy
right in the SEAL Teams
and that's where I spent my my whole
adult life and it was a incredible
experience worked with a bunch of
awesome people and got to do things that
I had dreamed about doing since I was a
little kid well what should we know
about like the life of a Navy SEAL that
you don't get in the movies or or
however else we just sort of imagine
these lives to be I would say the
biggest thing to remember is is that
that people in the SEAL Teams and people
in the military in general they're
people they're just normal people they
go home they got wives they got kids
they're trying to live a normal life and
then their job requires them to do
things that aren't very normal and so
they you know for me I kind of learned
to compartmentalize what I was doing in
the military and when I'd come home now
is I tell us to police officers and
firefighters and military guys today
don't when you get home don't bring your
uniform home don't wear your uniform
home like physically change your take
your uniform off leave it at work put on
your your civilian clothes and you go
home and be a civilian we
how hard is that though once you're sort
of in that locked mindset which
obviously has so much to do with the
things that you write about and why your
message actually is is working and
helping people you say how hard is it it
can be hard it can be hard you know
because you've got one life that you're
living where decisions are really
consequential and then you've got your
regular life that you're living and
things aren't that they aren't as
consequential you know I had a situation
where I was at work and there was a lot
of stuff going on at work they were they
were redeploying people to Afghanistan
there was big decisions that were being
made at work and I remember I came home
from work one day and like I said try to
try to leave my work at work but I'm
sitting there thinking about how all the
stuff is gonna unfold and my wife you
know I got home and my wife because I
can't believe this and I was like what
happened is everything okay and she says
you know the no it's not okay the the
Disney on Ice is the same night some
other dance for the kids and I'm
thinking hey if that's if that's the
biggest worries my wife has then that's
a positive thing ten life's pretty good
yeah life's pretty good yeah so how
quickly did you realize that you wanted
to sort of bring these ideas about
personal responsibility and sort of
owning your life and all that into sort
of that world
the world where Disney on Ice Matters a
mess of it yeah it's I was about six
months from retiring I had a friend that
was the CEO of a big company and he said
I want you to come and talk to my
executives about combat leadership and I
said hey sure you know sounds sounds
cool so I went and did it
and when I got and I don't think he
really knew what to expect you know
because I'm look like a knuckle-dragger
and a least a good portion I actually am
a knuckle-dragger
and so we bring me in the talk and I
thought I think he was maybe thinking I
tell some cooler stories and that'd be
that'd be great
but I actually started talking about how
you lead and when I got done he came up
to me and said I want you to do this for
every division that I have in my company
and I said well you know I'm retiring
and he said well I'll give you money and
I said
okay so I started working with all the
different divisionals
and at one of those division meetings
the CEO of the parent company was there
and when I got done he came up to me and
said I want you to come and talk to all
my CEOs for all these companies that
Helen and he owned like 45 or 50
companies so I went and did that and
when I went and talked to those
companies of course then a bunch of
those CEOs came up to me and said hey I
want you to come and talk to my company
so that's kind of the way that it
started and it didn't take me very long
at all I mean it it actually was the
very first company that first guy that I
talked to when they started when that
group started telling me about the
problems they were having I was sitting
there thinking myself well that's all
these problems in the steel platoons
when I was training steel platoons this
is the same thing it's leadership yeah
were you surprised that the big
successful businesses were having such a
leadership crisis I was surprised for
about five minutes and then I realized
that these are all human beings these
are the same human beings that are in a
seal platoon in an army company and in a
business and they're all they all have
the same idiosyncrasies that they have
the same egos the same personalities you
can see it all and when you've seen it
all over and over again it becomes
pretty evident pretty clear when you're
looking at it and the last job that I
have my SEAL Teams I was training while
running the SEAL training for the West
Coast SEAL Teams and this isn't a
training where you see like the guys
carrying the boats on their heads and
carrying logs around and doing a bunch
of push-ups and stuff the training that
I ran was the training where seals
actually learned to go into combat and
fight the enemy and this is where we
really start focusing on combat
leadership and so in this training that
I ran we got to take seal platoons and
put them through really tough training
scenarios very realistic training
scenarios over and over and over again
so every night I basically be putting a
new seal platoon through another
training scenario which the next night
will be another seal platoon going
through the same training scenario and
then the next time be another seal
platoon going through the same Chinese
snare so you take these different seal
tunes and what's different about a seal
platoon what's different about a seal
platoon is really just boils down to the
leadership because we've got 16 seals
and a seal guys are basically the same
sure there's some there's a bell curve
there's some top-end performers there's
low-end performers there's a bunch of
guys in the middle so the real variation
on their performance was based almost on
a percent on their on their leadership
in fact it was a hundred percent on
their leadership
so I got to see this and I got to watch
these leadership scenarios unfold over
and over again and see what leadership
things worked and what didn't work and
and so by the time I left that job and
entered the civilian sector I'd watched
some random team of leaders inside of my
organization
and I'd say no - all their strategic
Master doesn't get it down to the
frontline troops they need to
communicate this better or o their
departments aren't working together they
need to cover move for each other or
their mission is way too complex and
that no one has any idea what they're
actually supposed to be doing so they
need to simplify this or that this
senior leader is making all the
decisions and therefore everything's
moving really slow and nothing's
happening at a good rate of speed so
they need to use decentralized matter
and it was just so obvious when I
started how much of leadership in
general do you think is innate vs.
learned obviously you're teaching people
the learn part but there has to be some
element that's an aid right yeah there
absolutely is and there's the the
analogy that I give and I don't play
video games but I've seen it but on
video games there's you have a character
in a video game and you'll have a
certain level of intelligence is a
certain level of strength and a certain
level of agility and those levels are
what you get and then you work with well
it's the same thing for a leader and
there's different there's different
characteristics that you get that are
good for leadership right if you're
someone that's really articulate that's
a great thing to have to be a good
leader because you want the human beings
if you're talking to to understand what
you're actually saying so and different
people are naturally more articulate
than other people mm-hmm it's good to be
able to look at complex problems and be
able to simplify them right that's a
that's a very powerful tool to have a
really complex thing to solve and be
able to look at it and say okay simplify
it and then simplify it not only for
yourself so you can decide what to do
but simplify it for your team so they
understand what to do hmm that's that's
a characteristic that some people have
the the one that I bring up a lot
because it's very obvious is is being
loud because if you're in a leadership
position you need to be able to make
people hear you and some people are born
with a very loud voice I was luckily
born with a very loud voice and it's
inherited from my genes right and my
kids inherited it my kids are all can be
very loud which is so
time's problematic you know but if you
can't bark a command so that people can
hear you in a machine-gun fight no one's
be able to do what you ask them to do
yeah so there's these different
characteristics and you can improve upon
them so if you're not very articulate
you can read and you can write and you
can speak and you become more articulate
if you are not very good at simplifying
problems you can start looking at
complex problems and thinking about how
you can simplify them and you can get
better at that the being loud part is
that there's a definitely a genetic
aspect of that so sure you can learn to
project your voice more but some people
aren't very loud they're just born that
way and so what does a person do in that
situation well what a person does in
that situation is when they have to give
an order they tell one of the loud
mouths in their platoon to tell everyone
to get over in this other building now
and that loud mouth will pass a word and
so what you do is the leaders you find
members for your team that can
complement your weaknesses so there are
parts that you can improve and there are
parts that you can't improve and if you
the only real impediment to improving is
someone that doesn't have the humility
to say you know what I think I could
work on being more articulate or you
know what I think I could work on
solving problems and making them more
simple or you know what I'm not that
loud and instead of saying you know what
that's not a good way to lead and said I
say you know what I'm not that loud but
Billy over here is loud so I'm gonna let
him put the word out when it needs to
get put out but if you think that
humility to do that you won't improve as
a leader have you found those people
that even if you lay out what the right
you know skills are that they have to
work on or where their blind spots are
etcetera etcetera that they just can't
whether it's ego or whatever else that
they just can't that you just certain
people you just can't get through to
absolutely it's it's a horrible
situation to be in and in the SEAL Teams
those guys will get fired in the
civilian sector generally those guys get
fired because I mean you go into a
company and you've got a CEO that is not
listening to anyone I'll pour down the
chain you'll not listen to the board not
listen to do subordinates how is he
going to improve he's not going to and
by the way why does he need to improve
he needs to improve because his company
isn't doing well so but this person
might think hey you know I'm great
I'm not gonna learn anything from
anybody I'm just gonna keep doing it my
way
and that guy's not gonna stay in that
job because they don't have the humility
to say you know what I'm probably doing
some things wrong that's why we're not
making money and so I need to change
some of the things that I'm doing so we
can't make money but if you don't have
that attitude and you're not humble yeah
you'll end up getting fired so
conversely have you seen people that
basically had none of the skills that
have been able to overcome it just
through perseverance that just innately
don't have the leadership traits that
don't have you know they don't speak
loud
they aren't clear they can't exist but
just out of sheer sort of force of will
there's there's all these little aspects
that you have you can improve upon right
now you you're not gonna take I'm not
gonna lie to you and say you can take
somebody that has no aptitude for
leadership and they're gonna turn into a
great leader that that's probably not
gonna happen but you can't take someone
that has minimal aptitude for leadership
and they can improve the areas where
they need to improve they can complement
themselves with a team that can cover
for the areas where they're weak and
they can end up doing a great job in a
leadership position for sure yeah so
handing some of this stuff off people
don't think of that
in certain ways when it comes to leaders
like they have to do everything or know
everything or something but actually
hand in some of this stuff off is is
good delegating actually is good oh yeah
absolutely
like for instance big shocker I don't
really like doing paperwork a lot you
know seem odd but I always had guys that
worked for me I'd figure out that guy
that was really good at administrative
stuff and there you go guess what he's
gonna do a bunch of administrative stuff
and that's great and so whatever areas
of weakness you have have something you
know get a member of your team recruit
someone bring someone on board that can
actually make these things happen and
it'll work out great
yeah are you kind of surprised how much
we need leadership sort of in society
right now that we seem to have like a
complete dearth of leadership I mean you
mentioned Jordan Peterson before when I
see the message that he's bringing to
these people it's really about getting
yourself together which is the most I
mean it's very consistent with your
message yeah but but there's but the
people that are coming are sort of
looking for a leader to say that that we
just don't have we seemingly don't have
good leaders right now do you think
that's a fair estimation
we do have good leaders there's plenty
of good leaders out there and I see him
all the time in the business world I
still work with the military and there's
great leaders inside the military
there's great leaders inside the
business world for sure
there's also always a lack of leadership
and I mean I you know on my podcast I
cover I cover books about war generally
first-person accounts and there's a lack
of leadership back then and there's good
leaders so I don't know if it's gotten
any better or worse but the fact of the
matter is that leadership is it's the
hardest thing in the world as far as I
know it's it's the hardest thing you
know people used to ask me when I when I
first got out of the military what was
the most complex you know operation that
you would plan on with like planning
operations isn't a big of a deal like
here's a bad guy here's the assets that
we have here's what we're gonna do to go
take them out I mean this is stuff that
generally it's it's not that hard to do
but the hard part is weeding human
beings and so why does it seem like
there's that we need better leadership
because you always need better
leadership and because leadership is so
hard to actually do properly yeah do you
think we need some sort of mandatory
military service to get some of this
through to young people I think military
service is great for people I know it
was it was great for me and it it worked
out really well for me but I really
don't believe in in mandatory service
because I really don't believe that it's
good for government to tell people what
you need to do yeah I don't really
support that but I definitely support
and encourage everyone to go in the
reserves you know come join that during
the army or the Marine Corps the Navy
Air Force Reserves where you go away for
you know six weeks or eight weeks and
you kind of learn what the military is
about and then you do one weekend a
month and two weeks in the summertime
for you know indefinitely so I think I
have a pretty good handle on your
politics but do you even have a label
that kind of works for you politically I
don't know you I don't know I don't know
what label I think it'd be pretty hard
to label if you were just sort of
summing up sort of your political
beliefs well what would you say I think
that I guess a broad statement would be
I don't think that the government is the
solution to our problems yeah I think
that Jen
unleashing individuals to try and make
things happen is the best way for things
worked it's it's consistent with
decentralized commands that are talking
talked about in the first book that I
wrote with my my brother life is you
can't control everything
you know centralized decision-making
does not work it doesn't work on the
battlefield it doesn't work in business
it doesn't work with governments so
that's you know broadly speaking yeah I
don't think that the government should
control what individuals are doing as
little as possible do there have to be
some rules and regulations in place
absolutely but the framework should be
as loose as possible just like if I'm
running a seal platoon it's not every
man for himself
here's our standard operating procedures
here's the areas where we commit to
disciplined process but then once you
understand those and you know those
you're allowed to operate freely within
those guidelines to execute the mission
and that's what works that's what makes
not just the seal things that's what
makes any good military unit good and
that's what makes good business is good
good businesses aren't good because
someone is micromanaging every single
decision good businesses are good
because people broadly understand the
direction they're heading they
understand that and they're allowed to
move forward as they see fit are you
shocked when you say something like that
which obviously I agree with a hundred
percent I mean all I talk about here is
personal responsibility over and over
that that doesn't seem to sort of be the
kind of flavor of the day at the moment
that with the this if you listen to
mainstream media it's sort of more well
the government should give you this and
we should take from some give to others
that there's a more feeling of you you
were owed something rather than you
gotta get something you're asking if I'm
surprised by that yeah because it
because the the way you're laying it out
it's obvious you know you mean like I
mean that in the best sense it's obvious
like yeah it's your life go go do
something that has value and and creates
the real easy answers no I'm not
surprised by it at all because if I come
here and offer you something for free
why would you not want it why would you
not want to take it if I say hey you can
have this house for free and you'd say
okay that seems like a good deal to me
right and so yeah sure I understand why
people think that sounds like a good
idea because it's something
for free and they want to just in their
own individual world they think okay I
do want to take advantage of this but I
get something for free so it doesn't
surprise me at all the what is
unfortunate is if you can't draw the
line between hey everyone gets
everything for free and there's a price
to that that somebody's gonna have to
pay that's work because there is some
costs hidden in there somewhere
somewhere yeah so tell me what it was
like when he started writing cuz that
must have been a whole other ball of wax
you know it was I was actually an
English major in college and I went to
college halfway through my Navy career I
started off as an enlisted I went to
college and then became an officer then
went to college eventually so and the
reason I was an English major was
because believe it or not when you're an
officer in the military and actually
almost any job in the military you have
to write you not just have to write you
have to read you have to understand
because you have to write concept of
operations documents that are going to
be pushed up the chain of command and
they're gonna read through them and ask
questions and and look at the document
and try and comprehend what it is that
you're trying to do you got to write
evaluations for your troops and your
your troops are getting promoted based
on the evaluations that you write same
with awards you got to write awards same
thing with its after actions reports so
if you do an operation and things don't
go well you have to be able to
articulate and explain that what
happened and then pass that word on so
everyone understands now that you're
you're being given Direction verbal
direction yes of course but you're given
written direction as well you're given
missions in a written format or you're
given rules of engagement in a written
format written by lawyers and I realized
while I was a young enlisted guy and
then as a junior officer what I really
need to be able to do is understand and
communicate well up and down the chain
of command so when I went to college I
said yeah I want to learn English I want
to get good at it and so that's what I
did and so obviously I did a bunch of
writing and a ton of reading when I was
and when I was an English major in
college and then when I was in the
military writing your writing all time
and then when when when I got out and I
was working with these companies and
grew really quickly and that's why my my
buddy who was one of the two commanders
that worked for me in the battle Ramadi
Lake babban
he he was getting out of the Navy too
and you know I said we start I started
need some covering I said a man you want
to want to jump in and get some of this
and he was all on board and then as we
started doing this people would always
say hey you have this stuff written down
anywhere do you have a document you can
give us and so we eventually wrote it
down and then that's how the that's how
the first book came yeah can you lay out
a little bit about the Battle of Ramadi
you basically you sort of wrote the
plans the person that led the battle of
Hammadi that I was in was a guy named
Sean McFarland who was a colonel at the
time he retired as a general just a
super smart incredibly competent and and
great leaders a great leader and he came
in with so I had 40 SEALs with me right
I had 40 seals with me and 60 support
people Colonel MacFarland had 5600 Man
armored Brigade that we supported and we
helped them we work together in the
battle Ramadi vicious fighting very
tough battle and really took a city that
was completely controlled by the
insurgents in 2005/2006
and by early 2007 it was almost
completely pacified so it was it was
incredible it was a kind of incredible
turnaround and an incredible testament
to the capability of you know the US
Armed Forces do you guys pay any
attention to what's going on politically
back home when you're halfway across the
world yes absolutely you have to pay
attention to what's going on politically
back home you know and if especially
like at this time when we deployed to
Ramadi so it's 2005-2006 this is
smack-dab in the middle of the rising
negative public opinion about the war in
Iraq it's also where we had our own
government officials here in America
that we're saying this is unwinnable
this is another Vietnam this is a
quagmire we shouldn't be there to bring
everyone home so yeah you you absolutely
hear those things and that's not good
that's not it's not a positive thing
it's not a positive thing to have your
own government officials in America
saying that you cannot win and meanwhile
you're going out on an operation does
that that must drive you guys crazy more
than anything else
the political elite that often have no
idea what's happening on the ground that
are just spouting off stuff for sure for
sure but as I said it's you listen to it
but you can only pay something so much
attention to it there's so much other
things to focus on I mean you think
about it a little bit but you're not
caught up in the 24-hour news cycle like
you know like people can tend to do here
in America because you're working and
you're getting back from one operation
you're preparing for another operation I
got guys in the field
I got another element in the field I'm
going the field it's you don't have time
to be sitting around hey I wonder what
this politician is saying about what
we're doing how much you have leadership
that you brought to it was just about
managing stress for your guys just
making sure that they were actually okay
in the midst of the chaos yeah
absolutely you have to do some of that I
mean it's it's a it's a balancing act
between all kinds there's all kinds of
things that you're trying to juggle at
the same time and managing stress on the
guys is definitely one of them and in a
situation where you're getting guys
wounded and your guys are getting killed
that stress meter can get pegged out
pretty quick so you have to manage it
you have to do it to the best your
ability that's it's it's hard it's hard
because the war is going to keep going
and you are going to keep you you have
work that needs to continue so the
stress is going to build up on the
troops and it's different for every guy
you know the frontline SEAL or soldier
or marine they're worried about getting
blown up they're worried about getting
shot and killed they're worried about
their friends getting shot killed
they're worried about their friends
getting blown up when you're in charge
of a bunch of guys you're and you're
worried about all those guys and and not
happening to them you're worried about
if we make a mistake if we do something
wrong if we caused some massive
collateral damage that has a negative
strategic impact like that's you have
all those stresses and you know to
control stress what do you do that's
like you look at the things you can't
control the things you can't control
you focus on the things you can't
control and the things that you can't
control you do your best to mitigate and
then you don't worry about because
they'll drive you crazy
yeah what do you make of sort of where
we're at now
having lived through the Iraq war like
was it the right thing to do should we
have done things differently should we
have not just announced we were leaving
one day the whole the whole thing no the
whole thing is that the hindsight is
20/20 and any normal human being can
look back at American history as a whole
and find out all the mistakes that we've
made which are you know infinite right
we make an infinite number of mistakes
and we do the best to try and repair
those once they've taken place the so
for me to look at it from that angle
it's like okay yeah there's all kinds of
mistakes we make as a country we have
make as a country and we will make as a
country mm-hmm
but the best way for me to kind of
rationalize or not even rationalized
because I don't think it needs
rationalization but I when I look at it
from a granular level which is which is
very straightforward we went into a city
the city of Ramadi that was being
controlled by Sikh insurgents the most
sadistic evil subhuman people that you
can imagine they were raping torturing
skinning people alive murdering whole
families beheading people and when we
went in there and again I'm not talking
about we as this small group of seals
I'm talking about when this massive
force of us coalition and Iraqi forces
went into that city and liberated those
people from the torturous and sadistic
control of those insurgents the people
of Ramadi were overjoyed and they would
cheer when we killed insurgents and they
would tell us where insurgents were and
it was a beautiful transition to watch
and it didn't really take place until
after we left but after we left we saw
this it was peaceful
it was literally peaceful they went from
a complete warzone to a to a peaceful
city and where they were they had
markets open the street again they had
kids going school they had girls schools
now you know that's the
there wasn't it in the city of Ramadi
there was schools for girls huh and and
this was just unheard of while the
insurgents were there trying to you know
punish the the populace with their
psychotic brand of of al-qaeda Islam
right and and the people from body did
not want that at all and so from that
perspective it's like I go to sleep
every night
[Music]